der Inbegriff von Luxus als kleiner
Junge habe ich sobald ich in ein Hotel
eingecheckt bin wenn wir Urlaub gemacht
haben zunächst einmal dieses Menü
gesucht in dem die Minibar Preise und
der room service stand dann habe ich
gefühlt alles auswendig gelernt und mir
vorgestellt wie das wohl wäre das alles
zu bestellen natürlich durfte ich nichts
bestellen weil ich mein ich mein Kind
und ich hätte meinen eigenen Kindern
auch ein Vogel gezeigt wenn die mir
irgendwie die Karte runter bestellt
hätten aber der große max hat einen food
Channel und ich bin heute in einem der
luxuriösesten Hotels in München um mir
einfach zu bestellen worauf ich Lust
habe fünf Sterne Hotel Roomservice let's
go tatsächlich haben wir uns für genau
dieses Hotel entschieden wegen des
Roomservice ich habe ein bisschen
geschaut online wo es gut aussieht und
hier saß wirklich brutal aus ich muss
sagen das war aber auch das einzige was
mich wirklich umgehauen hat das war
nämlich echt teuer hier eine Nacht zu
buchen ansonsten die Zimmer sind relativ
unspektakulär man merkt auf jeden Fall
top Ausstattung sehr schön aber nicht so
außerordentlich extravagant oder
irgendwas fünf Sterne müssen irgendwoher
kommen ich glaube das hat viel mit der
Küche zu tun ich habe hier nicht wie es
früher als Kind immer ge und habe einen
schönen Umschlag in Leder gebunden
sondern nur ein QR-Code den werden wir
jetzt gemeinsam scannen und wir sehen
schon es gibt zwei Karten eine die 24/7
verfügbar ist das heißt ich könnte auch
mitten in der Nacht eine deftige
Gulaschsuppe oder eine bayerische
Brotzeit bestellen und eine die bis 22
Uhr quasi mit dem Restaurant zumacht
tatsächlich ist das die Karte auf die
ich verstärkt gucken möchte weil ich
glaube die ist krass also Leute lasst
uns den Hörer in die Hand nehmen und
einfach die Bestellung abgeben
1 0 1 wie wird man denn hier ist ja
auflegen wir müssen erstmal herausfinden
wie man dieses scheiß Telefon wie kann
das sein dass die Telefon nicht
funktioniert
[Musik]
Essen
ich glaube das Telefon funktioniert
nicht guten Abend hallo ich würde gerne
etwas bestellen auf Zimmer bisschen mehr
also mit Vorspeise Hauptspeise super
dann hätte ich gerne einmal das warme
Sauerteig Brot die Kohlrabi Spaghetti
Asia style
ach so das ist eine alte Karte
was passiert
ist eine alte Karte die haben extra
online diese Karte das ist einfach eine
alte
dankeschön gerne
eine Silber getäfelte Karte
sommerlicher Blattsalat mit Apfel
Dressing
geschmortemilch purata warmes
Sauerteigbrot der Boulangerie Vampire
okay das ist schon mal geblieben vom
Grill bayerisches Rinderfilet einaux
Entrecote Kalbsfilet Lammrücken im
kräutel Black Tiger Garnelen bayerische
Lachsforelle
lässt sich wirklich lesen wie ein
Gedicht ja also es ist vor allem fast
also es ist eigentlich nichts dabei wo
ich sagen würde das ist nicht
ansprechend hör bitte einfach mal nur
wer da fällt salam Rücken im
kräutermanntel mit aquarello Zitronen
Thymian Risotto man denkt 100 €
Restaurant es sind warte 5 € plus das
sind 48 Euro also fast und was wir noch
brauchen schauen wir jetzt ich habe die
Bestellung parat das liest sich so gut
also wenn das Essen kommt und gut ist
dann habe ich alles vergessen und dann
hätten wir gerne einmal den geschmortten
Pulpo TV von der gelbflossen Makrele und
das sauerte Brot Werder Felder
Lammrücken im kräutermanntel
aquarello Zitronen Thymian Risotto die
dämmiglaster zu werden gerne einmal das
Entrecote 300 Gramm Bio Rosmarin Wedges
ein Mini Louis caillant als Soße dazu
gerne die Nussbutter Hollandaise gerne
medium rare wenn wir schon dabei sind
wir nehmen auch noch einmal dass die
Tonkabohnen Creme
ja dann haben wir alles einmal bestellt
vielen Dank
das war meine schwierige Gefühl mich
irgendwie so als würde ich was illegales
machen richtig gut aus WoW aber vielen
Dank danke schön
[Musik]
alter Schwede so sehen
178 Euro in einem 5 Sterne Hotel aus
alter Schwede guckt euch das bitte
einfach einmal an Leute wir haben hier
die Rechnung
173,50 € 5 charge also dafür dass hier
hochgebracht wurde und ich sage euch
eins ich weiß nicht was es ist es ist
dieser Wagen der ins Zimmer geschoben
wird ist es die Tatsache dass ich
einfach in meinem Hotelzimmer sitze und
sage hey bring mir bitte das aufs Zimmer
irgendwas macht das hier 100 mal
spektakulärer als wenn ich im Restaurant
sitzen würde ich weiß nicht ob ich bin
ob ihr denkt ich bin verrückt vielleicht
könnt ihr teilen ein paar Sachen optisch
erstmal was für ein Eindruck seht ihr
diese Vielfalt seht ihr diese Farben
verschiedene Teller verschiedene Formen
richtig geil aber der Niklas fehlt hat
mir bestellt dieses Steak hat nie im
Leben 300 Gramm also wirklich im Leben
und wer mir ein größeres gewählt wenn
ich jetzt schätzen müssen würde ich
sagen es hat 250 maximum R 200 irgendwie
ist das ein bisschen schade dass die
Portion ein bisschen klein ausfallen
hier oben auf dem Zimmer aber das so zu
bekommen ist natürlich deinen Traum ich
will nicht zu lange Zeit verlieren
sondern das ganze probieren starten wir
mit sewitsche auch hier wieder einfach
schön Schwertfisch Limetten juso-gel das
sind wirklich Begriffe und Kombinationen
die man wirklich aus der Gourmetküche
kennt und das einfach in sein
Hotelzimmer gebracht zu bekommen
unglaublich wenn es jetzt auch gut
schmeckt
[Musik]
der Fisch schmeckt wirklich frisch
Limette hat diesen Zitrus Punch der von
der Seite kommt eine absolut sommerliche
Vorspeise boah voll ausbalanciert total
frisch also wirklich krank nehmen wir
uns hier etwas von unserem lauwarm
Boutique oder wie ist das Boulangerie
brogerie Sauerteig französische Bäckerei
die uns ein schönes Sauerteigbrot back
welches wirklich noch ein bisschen warm
innen drin ist gehen hier einmal rein in
das ganze auf und probieren
[Musik]
so so real Alter sieht einfach so krass
aus Brot ist hammergeil mit 4,50 das
günstigste heute aber sein Geld auf
jeden Fall werden beim room service
kenne ich das eigentlich mit diesen
Hauben ja ja oder ja Thema Wärme so ein
Steak young stimmt
wenn wir länger warten ich nehme direkt
hier ein Stückchen auch hier wie schon
wieder so schön mit so gehen Soßen
gearbeitet wird der hieß cremiger Pulpo
und ihr wisst es vielleicht Pulpo cremig
zu bekommen ist nicht die einfachste
Aufgabe der Welt guck mal ob sie es
geschafft haben
also das ist schon fast komisch wie
cremig wird erstmal das nicht mehr super
warm ne ich weiß nicht ob er sein soll
könnte eine kalte Vorspeise sein aber hä
was ist das ich habe einmal so guten
Pulver gegessen als wir Maximilian
Lorenz der sternekocht ja auch schon
häufiger auf dem Kanal zu Gastwerk
selbst höchstpersönlich in seiner Küche
eingebracht hat jetzt esse ich ihn
gerade in dem Hotelzimmer welches
Risotto ist das noch mal das ist nicht
nur Vorlesen das ist nämlich nicht
irgendein Risotto nein es ist das
klassische aquarello Zitrone Thymian
Resort gehen wir rein leichte Haut oben
drauf wer weiß ob eine Haube das
vielleicht verhindert hätte aber innen
drin wie WoW aber richtig da ist richtig
viel Käse drin
aquarello ist ein besonderer Risotto
Reis der eine besonders hohe Güte hat
ich dachte es sei Käse aus gutem Grund
weil das ist so unfassbar käsig das ist
das erste Risotto das mich an
Käsespätzle erinnert verdammt lecker
übertroffen und verfehlt auf einmal
schneiden wir einmal das medium rare und
record ist 300 Gramm hat an ich wünsche
dir eine Waage dabei ne weil das ist so
super schwer so zu behaupten aber wir
haben auch aber man kann ja mal schauen
wenn jetzt die Gas Stufe nicht stimmt
bin ich wirklich enttäuscht dann ist es
weniger und nicht richtig gedacht Medium
mehr entscheiden wir gemeinsam
ja das sieht super es ist ein schönes
Medium das sieht super aus guck mal das
hat so wenig groß ich glaube dass sie
das Suite gar nicht soll so sein
hauptsache es schmeckt gut gucken wir ob
es das tut das schmeckt nicht so super
Fleisch aber ne also das geht wirklich
schon bitterliche dir darum
stand jetzt sage ich dir ganz ehrlich
ist mir das das Geld nicht wert das
kostet nämlich 48,50 Leute
niemals niemals geht zum Metzger eures
Vertrauens und grillt euch das beste
Steak dass ihr im gesamten Jahr Essen
werdet ich habe jetzt echt schon mich
darauf eingestellt dass das hier so ein
so wird tanzen und so durch perfekt ist
weil es hat mich auch direkt auch so ein
bisschen auf so Sterneküche Gourmet
Küche eingestimmt auch wieder Pulver ich
will wieder eine Freude erleben kleiner
Erfrischung zwischendurch Caesar Salad
ist so auch auf der 24.7 Karte zu finden
denke der sitzt also sieht das Salat und
Hotel ordentlich cremig oder so ein paar
getrocknete oder Konflikte Tomaten mit
dabei oder vor allem orange trocknete
Tomaten was für mich so ein bisschen so
gerührt nicht gekauft oder zumindest
nicht billig eingekauft sondern weil
findest du sonst nicht sein soll das ist
nicht was sein soll gucken wir ob das
Land eine bessere Fleischspeise ist
kostet 43 €. Leute 43 Euro das tut weh
Alter
schöne Kruste schneidet sich butterweich
tolle Farbe die so ein bisschen in
Richtung dann geht würde ich sagen dann
kann ja auch so wunderschön rosa sein
probier erstmal so und dann mit unserer
Hollandaise ihr hast du eine schöne
Charakteristik das schmeckt mehr nach
etwas oben ist fast wie eine schwarze
bei einem Krustenbraten das schon gut
aber das haut mich auch nicht aus dem
Socken dicker das ist halt auch einfach
nicht das was wir bestellt haben das
sind keine 250 g und das sind niemals
300 das ist echt schade egal rein in die
Nussbutter Hollandaise ich glaube die
ist ungefähr das ist unfair
immer lieber die Soße gebracht dann wäre
das Steak vielleicht auch mal ein
bisschen das hätte wahrscheinlich so ein
bisschen den Steak Charakter
hervorgehoben potato watch
die haben aber einen schönen Crunch die
sind richtig gut noch mal rein in die
Nussbutter erstoch dass wir noch mal in
die Augen rufen ohne dieses Video wenn
ich das hier gerade machen würde würde
ich mich wieder König der Welt fühlen so
vor diesem Essen zu setzen
mit deiner Freundin lässt so das Essen
hier aus Zimmer
im Bett zu essen wenn ihr Fernsehen
schauen
das bleibt auch einfach eine
außergewöhnliche Erfahrung auch wenn das
ein bisschen getrübt hat weil es halt
einfach teuer war es darf und soll auch
teuer sind wir sind im 5 Sterne Hotels
das Fleisch das darf seinen Preis ein
bisschen schade ist zu wenig ist und es
könnte noch perfekt sein fast alles
andere hat mich richtig umgehauen wir
essen das ganze jetzt für uns auf in
Ruhe genießen im Moment ein bisschen zum
Abschluss gibt es das Dessert und dann
beantworte ich euch die Frage ob ich das
ganze noch mal machen würde
[Musik]
173 € 50 immerhin kann ich sagen Erik
und ich sind beide pappsatt
ich kann wirklich sagen Erik und ich
sind pappsatt die Creme Brulee die ich
vor mir habe ich trotzdem noch gerne
probieren das Eis ist die ganze Zeit
perfekt stehen geblieben
also interessant auch viel mehr so ein
rhabarberschaum und so also es ist nicht
ein klassisches Eis aber sehr lecker
hier so getrockneten Rhabarber und
superflamiert ist natürlich nicht mehr
heiß jetzt kann man hier oben aber
klagt schön die Creme Brille selbst
ultra cremig und der
tonkabohnengeschmack wenn man nicht weiß
wie Tonkabohne schmeckt nach dieser
Creme Brulee weiß man es sehr lecker
sehr cremig mit schönes Dessert
also Leute wir hatten Höhen wir hatten
tiefen insgesamt ist das aber eine
unglaubliche Erfahrung und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass ich das machen konnte
wirklich auch ohne Kamera ohne alles ich
finde es einfach besonders so etwas
machen zu können dafür bin ich wirklich
happy das ist was ganz Besonderes das
ist was Einzigartiges das ist vielleicht
das einmalig ist die Sache ist folgende
wenn man in einem teuren Hotel
übernachtet sowieso und es einen guten
Service gibt dann finde ich kann man
sich das auf einmal gönnen ich
persönlich finde dieses Erlebnis so
besonders das ist für mich irgendwie was
ganz anderes als ein Restaurant besucht
so dass ich es auch mit meiner Freundin
nicht mehr mit dir Eric bestimmt noch
mal machen würde weil es einfach richtig
besonders finde zur heutigen Bestellung
hätten mit Sicherheit Sachen anders
bestellen können ihr wisst selbst was
dann wäre man günstiger wegbekommen wäre
trotzdem satt und es wäre einfach ein
besseres Gefühl aber alles in allem bin
ich wirklich Leute danke fürs zuschauen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video wieder
ich hoffe ihr hattet genauso viel Spaß
wie ich weitergeht im nächsten Video
hier aus München mit den Top Footballs
ich muss bis dahin wieder Hunger
bekommen